a rapper a Meek Mill is pushing for
criminal justice reform after his own
controversial legal troubles
Pennsylvania Supreme Court ordered mill
to be released from prison on bail two
weeks ago back in November a judge
ordered him to serve up to four years
for violating his probation after 2008
conviction on drug and weapons charges
now mill is appealing that conviction he
was sentenced to 11 to 23 months in
prison plus eight years probation eight
years many activists claim that Mills
treatment was unfair and harsh the
prominent names who support Mill include
jay-z comedian Kevin Hart Philadelphia
seven 76ers owner that's Michael Rubin
and New England Patriots owner that's
Bob Kraft Meek Mill is here with his
attorney Joe taco Pino for their first
live TV interview since Mills released
good morning to you both thank you
sunday was your 31st birthday yes I'm
thinking this is a very good birthday
present for you meek mill the
president's but you've been dealing with
this for 10 years you've been dealing
with this case for ten years and it all
started when you were accused of a drug
and weapons charge will you both say you
shouldn't have been convicted in the
first place so just take us briefly to
the beginning I was actually arrested by
a group a small group of officers that
was basically blacklist as corrupt
officers and I was found guilty for
pointing a firearm at a at a police
officer she said you did not do it I did
not do you had drugs
yeah covered media here we're like a lot
of stories of young black men reaching
for cell phones are actually having a
firearm and that point in at police they
said you had drugs they said I had drugs
they said pointing a firearm and that
was it
that was it and Joe you're saying he
should never been convicted because
because the entire case was based on a
corrupt lying proven perjurious police
officer who had a racial bias has got
Reggie Graham the Philadelphia District
Attorney's Office and and Yale you know
this is not a defense lawyer advocating
for his clients benefit the Philadelphia
District Attorney's Office has just
acknowledged that his conviction because
of constitutional violations needs to be
overturned so he
stalked by a system for ten years his
entire adult life for a conviction that
he should have never been convicted of
in the first place because the entire
case is based on perjurious testimony we
have to say we reached out to the
officer Reggie Graham and he has not
gotten back to us but part of the
problem too is this eight years
probation and that you got hit with all
these technical violations of violating
probation like popping a wheelie yeah
being late for an appointment
yeah on occasions you did test positive
though for marijuana yes yes yes no not
marijuana for opioids only protested
positive for opioids ever I was addicted
to using painkillers for actually a few
years of my life which was one of the
biggest battles in my life that I
overcame and I overcame these battles
through rehabilitation and once I
rehabilitated myself I was still sent to
prison almost a year later me where
would you be right now if you were just
Meek Mill who nobody knew if you didn't
have all these powerful people who
raised your case up and made people all
day in prison you know being in prison
this happens to minorities on a daily
basis where they don't have a voice and
I just came from it's almost like cities
within sized cities inside prisons where
people have no contact to the world no
context of the median
I was extremely blessed to have people
that was powerful that vol me because
growing up in environments we grew up in
being locked up by a cop was normal I
don't know if you ever see my mug shot
of I did stitches on both sides of my
face who were pretty beat up yeah I was
like we talked about it one time that
was the year of 2007 life goes on
because we see that on a daily base and
I'm just lucky to have people of power
and much influence to stand behind me
leave didn't you you said when you were
in jail used to dream of getting out
yeah and now that you're out you're
saying that this case is so much bigger
than you yeah
yeah this always has been bigger than me
I heard a lot of people who like comment
only like I don't think he should be the
face I don't care about being the face I
care about saving people lives and
helping
the world become a better place if I can
well you can help other people who don't
have the friends you did perhaps out of
their situation is that the hope yes
even being on shows like this platforms
like this to be able to speak about
these type topics is enough if I could
say one or if I could save a million
people is enough for me I just want to I
felt like God put me on a path to bring
this to the light and make this a
positive situation because actually I
look at it as I was a sacrifice I had to
do six months out of prison just about
two weeks ago the district attorney and
the probation officer both said Joe that
he should not get any jail time that's
back in November one yeah two to four
years as judge judge bringing in two to
four years for violating probation
technical violations non-criminal
offenses both the prosecutor at the time
and the probation officer were both in
charge of patrolling the sort of the
jurisdiction of probation violations
both said he's been an exemplary
probationer and these are technical
violation she doesn't belong in jail the
judge excoriated them and gave him two
to four years on top of his already
served sentence for a crime he should
never been convicted that's not yet in
Kentucky that I explained a technical
violation the technical violation is not
a crime I was used as a as an example
with the young kids and Starbucks if I
was in Starbucks and got handcuffs put
on me and was arrested I would be in
technical violation no matter if I was
found guilty or innocent you're in a
technical violation and legally the
judge would still be able to sentence me
to years in jail just because I was on
probation no matter if I committed a
crime or I did and its police contact
and growing up as an inner-city kid a
black young minority we see police
contact on a daily basis it's not me
right now in the position I am but so
close this out with the the thing you
most want people to know I want people
to know this situation is about is it's
not about me on any level it's about
changing policies and and throwing
things to protect people like myself who
always who deserve the second chance
even if you're innocent is is millions I
would say thousands of other people in
situations like me who don't have a
voice and
I would love for the rest of the world
the United States to stand up and make
America one cuz I always explained it as
being two different America two
different Americas and a lot of people
they didn't understand what I was saying
and I would just like to bring people
together and make things work you said
you don't want to be the poster you
don't want to be the poster child but I
think me it's too late I think they know
your story really illustrates I'm not
concerned with taking credit abilities
for anything uh I'm a musical artists I
came I started making music to take care
of my family they escaped well you do it
with great humility - yeah you do I
appreciate you know and Joe taka Pino
thank you so much for being there for me
I appreciate to see you